well I would say there is a link between
the loss of senses and creativity not
just alcohol but drugs or pathology and
of course these have been the subject of
many studies very fascinating and many
tries the question is to know how much
what provocations the loss of the
control is needed for that or is the
Creator capable are able to get until
these experimental points without what
creates the loss of the sense in other
words this is always the the flirt I
would say with a border between control
and loss of control or between
consciousness and unconsciousness that
is so fascinating and has been so
fascinating especially at some moments
of mankind and that we can explore today
probably with a more acute way thanks to
neurobiology
you